okay
let's talk about marvel zombies for a
second this what if episode was amazing
oh my god so something to keep in mind
uh sometime today maybe around the time
this video goes up i'm not entirely sure
uh i will have a video on comics
explained that takes all the marvel
zombie stories and combines them into
one big video we call it our full story
series but basically it'll all convince
it all down into one big video so you
guys can basically get the whole
treatment when it comes to marvel
zombies and marvel comics having said
that the what-if episode was fantastic
now here's the thing about marvel
zombies because this confuses the hell
out of people so when it comes to marvel
zombies there's two universes to keep in
mind the first one is 2149 and the
second one is 91 126. the reason why
this matters is 2149 is basically where
the zombie virus initially picked up
with right where marvel zombies
initially opened up where like magneto's
fleeing for his life and he's trying to
fight off all the different zombies
eventually he's killed and so on and so
forth and the zombies just kind of
spread throughout the world over the
course of the series what you end up
learning is that the entire concept of
the marvel zombies basically happening
in the first place was essentially a
time loop that what had happened is that
in earth 2149 robert reynolds the
century was infected with the zombie
virus he ended up being transferred
along with a handful of other zombies
who were trying to escape their
dimension to infect other universes he
ended up being transferred to a new
universe called 91 126 and basically
that universe fell as well right that
whole universe was taken over by the
zombie apocalypse and so the watcher in
that alternate reality sent robert
reynolds into the past of earth 2149 and
that's what caused the zombie apocalypse
so it's a loop destined to repeat
forever until the end of all things
right at the end of the multiverse and
it was a way to basically keep the whole
thing contained so the zombies couldn't
get outside of those two universes and
infect other universes across the cosmos
nonetheless marvel zombies was great
right the whole story itself was
fantastic right it was written by robert
kirkman the guy who wrote the walking
dead marvel zombies was his test bed he
did that before he did the walking dead
but the whole episode was fantastic
there were some great humorous moments
in this episode right one of the things
that i love is like what is it super
giant i think is what his name was
technically that great big huge hulking
looking guy from like thanos's uh coal
obsidian his name's actually black dwarf
but for obvious reasons marvel doesn't
use that name in the mcu but i love
seeing him and the ebony maw who still
has the best name ever of any villain in
the history of comics the ebony maw i
love that name god i love that name so
much nonetheless so so i love like they
show up and they just are immediately
attacked by the avengers and then like
turn it into zombies i love that right i
like that a lot of it was told from the
perspective of banner i like the way
they chose this right the banner comes
crashing down to earth and basically it
happens in place of what would be
infinity war and avengers end game i dig
this right i dig that whole concept one
of the things i also loved is how it
started what a neat simple little
explanation there about how the whole
zombie apocalypse took place right that
like hank pym went into the quantum
realm to find his wife janet and
ultimately she had basically been
infected by what was in essence a virus
right the zombie infection or as we
would interpret it to be the zombie
infection and then she bites hank they
basically grow up to their normal sizes
they attack scott and then the whole
zombie apocalypse breaks out from there
i loved it right i absolutely loved the
way that happened how small how neat
what i also love too and this is one of
the things that people kind of tend to
under appreciate when it comes to
different stories like this in marvel
comics the cast the roster the surviving
heroes i love that right it's very easy
for us to look at that and say okay so
the surviving heroes are obviously going
to be all the major players right iron
man captain america thor all those guys
they're obviously going to be the ones
to make it i loved that they weren't
right i loved that they were not the
ones that came out on top on this one of
the big questions that i found myself
asking is
where's thor
[Laughter]
[Music]
where's thor now there's a couple
different options here right a couple
different possibilities one is that thor
and the rest of the asgardians are just
still out there in space right and that
either they were destroyed by thanos or
that thanos got to earth before they did
we don't fully know how things went down
there i mean in all reality it makes
sense right i mean like thanos at the
end of the episode is in possession of
all the infinity stones with the
exception of the mind stone which is
currently in possession of the survivors
who are heading to wakanda or at least
last we saw they were heading to wakanda
so it makes sense that given the nature
of like infinity war and so on loki had
that stone with him and during infinity
war he handed it over to thanos so we
know that at least last we saw loki
still had it in his possession and so it
makes sense that thanos would have shown
up like he did during the the beginning
of infinity war but instead of like
sparing the asgardians he basically
killed them all but the fact that banner
lands there he doesn't say anything
about thor right he's not like i'm the
last surviving member of everybody who
was there with thor and they're all dead
right thanos killed everybody right like
thanos is coming and he killed everyone
it's not like he really says that right
so we're just kind of left to figure out
what's going on with thor i doubt we'll
get a part two to this if we do it'll
probably end up being in the next season
of what if or maybe even a season after
and it'd be kind of cool they did that
right if like the the future seasons of
what if like the black mirror series on
netflix like were future seasons built
on uh basically previous seasons i would
love to see that happen but we don't
really know what's going on with thor we
simply just know that he's not there
having said that if he did become a
zombie they all would have been screwed
even faster than they were man because
thor with mjolnir just like just lunging
this this hammer at people but it also
begs the question would thor be worthy
of lifting his hammer if he was a zombie
answer that question down in the
comments do you guys think thor would
have been worthy to lift his hammer if
he had been a zombie i'm curious what
y'all's responses are on that but again
beyond that the whole thing was just it
was beautifully handled it was
beautifully done it was beautifully
written i loved it i absolutely loved it
and like all the what if series it
really kind of leaves you asking like
what comes next right i mean the only
episode of the what if series it kind of
gave us a sort of finality right like
this is how things end for this universe
was episode four right the one with
doctor strange where he basically
destroyed his own universe but even then
it kind of leaves you wondering what
comes next because as far as we're aware
steven strange is the sole survivor of
his universe so we don't know what'll
happen with him with this one like
literally thanos is just standing there
as a zombie with the infinity gauntlet
presumably ready to blink out half the
life in the universe but we don't really
know what form this is going to take how
it's all going to unfold if the heroes
will defeat him and get the infinity
gauntlet from him and then maybe use
some kind of witchcraft and magic to use
a combination of the time stone and
other things to set things back to where
they're supposed to be i would love to
see the conclusion the real conclusion
of what this story would look like it's
one of the most fascinating things about
the what if series right in the comics
themselves you usually get a definitive
ending you usually get like a conclusion
it usually in some form or fashion wraps
back around to the mythos behind the
characters themselves a really good
example is punisher's family dying right
a lot of you guys know the punisher
frank castle his family was killed in
central park that's what led him to
become the punisher in the first place
in the what if series his family never
dies in central park so he never really
becomes the punisher as we know him but
instead his family's basically killed by
crooked cops that leads him to become
the punisher and the story basically
goes forward and says this is how the
frank castle became the punisher in this
alternate reality right so it usually
ties in but it still gives you a
definitive ending with most of the
what-if episodes here it's left
open-ended to the point where you can
actually see some of these elements and
even a lot of these elements being
incorporated in the future of the mcu in
the movies themselves right doctor
strange 2 and the vents that are going
to involve kang the quantum realm things
along those lines it's a lot of cool
possibilities here that's one of the
things that i love but for this episode
i actually really wanted to see the
conclusion i was a little disappointed
by the fact that the movie just sort of
ended with thanos standing there with
the infinity going on and it's just kind
of like he's probably going to get the
mind stone and blink out half the life
in the universe right or will he like
i'm kind of disappointed that we didn't
get that
i really would have liked the definitive
ending to this you know another thing
that i'm a little disappointed about is
that we didn't get to see the full-on
fight between wanda and the incredible
hulk that would have been cool having
said that i did love the whole thing
about what vision was doing right
because that seems like a very vision
thing to do that vision loves wanda
he'll do whatever he needs to do in
order to help wanda and in his mind if
there's a way to cure wanda then he's
got to keep wanda alive but the only way
to keep wanda alive seemingly is to
ensure that she's adequately fed in
order to keep her docile otherwise
she'll do exactly what she did which is
lose her mind and then just start
attacking things break out of the
facility and then fly off into the
sunset and then possibly end up being
killed by somebody out there who's
hunting zombies and so i thought it was
kind of cool that vision was basically
luring people into safety right by kind
of broadcasting that message saying hey
this is a safe space we're working on a
cure bring people there and then feed
them to wanda i mean it's dark you know
like it's dark and brutal but it was
kind of cool seeing black panther there
right seeing t'challa there which by the
way it was amazing to hear chadwick
boseman's voice again but seeing like
t'challa there is a person who had been
taken by by vision but he wasn't really
killed but i love that like they saved
him and basically he's heading back to
wakanda in order to ensure that they can
develop a cure stuff like that i love
that whole thing because the reality is
in that kind of a situation that's sort
of what you would expect somebody to do
maybe not necessarily a zombie
apocalypse but certainly like an end
time kind of situation like cormac
mccarthy's the road where people are
basically turning to cannibalism in
order to survive and then like you lure
people to a location under the false
pretense of it being a safe space and in
their desperation they will follow you
and then you feed on them right it's
it's pretty brutal but it also seems
very practical and very realistic with
regards to how an event like this would
unfold especially for the character of
vision but having said that i've seen a
lot of people on twitter who were
talking about how they think this is the
absolute best episode of the what if
series so far i gotta disagree i still
say doctor strange is the one to be i
still say episode number four is the
episode to beat for the what if series i
mean just the the stakes right the
stakes the emotion the the ability to
identify with the characters that whole
thing like just the feel of the episode
was just incredible right episode number
four was just an amazing episode i still
think that's the one to be this one's
second best it's definitely better than
any of the other ones right episodes one
two and three but i don't think it's
better than episode four having said
that i think we're still waiting for
what is it party thor and i think we're
waiting for uh ultron and vision merging
and i believe they get the infinity
stones we're still waiting on those two
episodes and maybe a couple more
honestly it's all just kind of blending
together for me at this point i'm just
i'm just riding the shows right i'm just
i'm just waiting one week to the next to
see what happens
but we still have a couple episodes to
go so it's too early to determine which
ones are the absolute best here but let
me know in the in the comments section
where you guys think this episode ranks
do you think it's the best episode do
you think it's the second best episode
is there one that you liked better than
this one let me know what you all think
but having said that guys this was a
fantastic episode god it was it was
beautifully done i absolutely loved it
but we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace